Il bravo storico assomiglia all'orco delle leggende,
«Quando sente odore di carne umana, sa che lì c'è la sua preda».
Fra quelli che fanno il mio mestiere è una delle frasi più famose,
ed è la frase più famosa di Mark Bloch,
il grande storico che ha rivoluzionato la storiografia del Novecento
e che proviamo a raccontare questa sera.
Tra noi storici il nome di Mark Bloch è un nome leggendario,
per il suo lavoro di storico e anche per la sua vita e per la sua morte.
Lui, a dire il vero, sembrava tutt'altro che un orco.
Io qui non ho le fotografie, ma le trovate su internet.
È un uomo tranquillo, con i baffetti,
con gli occhialini rotondi da intellettuale dell'inizio del Novecento,
anche un po' corpulento verso la fine della sua vita,
e però dietro quegli occhialini rotondi, come vedremo, c'era molto di inaspettato.
Allora, Mark Bloch nasce nel 1886 a Lione,
per caso, perché suo papà è professore all'Università di Lione,
ma quasi subito si trasferiscono a Parigi,
perché ovviamente nella carriera accademica francese
l'obiettivo di tutti i professori è arrivare a Parigi.
Sapete che la Francia è un paese molto stratificato e piramidale,
per cui le carriere consistono nel fatto di arrivare a Parigi.
Quindi Mark Bloch cresce a Parigi,
studia in uno dei grandi licei di Parigi,
Louis Le Grand,
dove hanno trovato le sue pagelle,
doveva essere un primo della classe insopportabile,
poi entra all'Ecole Normale.
È un percorso assolutamente standard.
Andate a vedere le biografie di tutti i grandi intellettuali francesi del Novecento
e troverete questo percorso qua, un grande liceo,
poi l'Ecole Normale o la Sorbona,
poi la cattedra in qualche liceo per qualche anno in provincia
in attesa di arrivare all'università.
È tutto normalissimo,
tranne per un dettaglio.
quel cognome che suona tedesco,
Bloch.
I Bloch sono ebrei alsaziani
e quando nel 1870,
sapete la guerra franco-prussiana,
nasce il Reich tedesco
e i tedeschi si impadroniscono dell'Alsazia e della Lorena
e ai cittadini viene offerta l'opzione di restare lì e diventare sudditi tedeschi
oppure restare francesi ed emigrare in Francia.
Il papà di Marc Bloch è uno di quella minoranza di alsaziani che decidono che loro sono francesi
e quindi torna in Francia.
Sono francesi al 100% i Bloch, sono ebrei,
ma l'antenato di cui Marc Bloch è più fiero ha combattuto per la rivoluzione francese
al tempo dell'assedio di Magonza nel 1793.
Sono francesi al 100% e per Marc Bloch per molto tempo
il fatto di essere ebreo per lui sarà solo un cognome, nient'altro.
C'è un dettaglio eloquente, è una stupidaggine ma ve la dico lo stesso.
In una cittadina di provincia francese c'è un liceo intitolato a Marc Bloch
e i ragazzi del liceo hanno messo su internet un testo
in cui si sforzano di dire qualcosa di questo grand'uomo a cui è intitolata la loro scuola
e dicono sì, questo mondo ebraico con questa sua grande tradizione culturale
questo mondo ebraico con il suo attaccamento alla famiglia, alla memoria familiare
chissà come ha influenzato Marc Bloch.
Il figlio di Bloch, uno dei figli, Etienne, che ha tenuto più di tutti gli altri fratelli
si è dato molto da fare per tenere viva la memoria del padre, ha costruito un sito,
pubblicato documenti e così via, Etienne sul suo sito di questa cosa scritta dai ragazzini del liceo
ha detto scemenze.
A casa nostra di essere ebrei non importava niente a nessuno, non erano credenti
e non si è mai minimamente parlato del fatto che avevamo gli antenati ebrei.
Dunque Marc è avviato una tranquilla carriera intellettuale, però naturalmente stiamo attenti agli anni come al solito.
È nato nel 1886, quindi ha 28 anni e ha già fatto come tutti il suo servizio militare,
è sergente della riserva, professore di liceo, quando a 28 anni gli capita quello che è capitato a Salvemini
che abbiamo raccontato ieri e capiterà anche a Kantorowicz che racconteremo domani per chi ci sarà.
Capita a tutti nel 1914 questa cosa che scoppia la prima guerra mondiale
e Marc Bloch viene mobilitato come sergente di fanteria
e si fa tutta la guerra, quattro anni al fronte e finisce la guerra da capitano.
Ora non tutti hanno presente il significato dei termini della gerarchia militare
ma cominciare da sergente ed essere promosso alla fine capitano
significa aver fatto una grossa carriera, vuol dire che tu quel mestiere lo sai fare.
Etienne Bloch, il figlio, ricorda che una volta un colonnello
che faceva di mestiere lo storico dell'esercito francese
gli ha detto io non conosco nessun altro caso
di uno che ha cominciato la guerra da sergente nel 1914
e la finita nel 1918 da capitano.
Magari gliel'ha detto per fargli piacere
magari ci sarà anche qualche altro caso
ma sicuramente vuol dire che il professor Bloch
si è rivelato un bravissimo ufficiale
si è fatto i suoi quattro anni di trincea
e nel corso di quei quattro anni
vi racconto questo aspetto perché lui ci teneva molto
è stato citato quattro volte per atti di valore all'ordine del giorno
cosa vuol dire citato all'ordine del giorno
vuol dire che ogni tanto, non tutti i giorni
il comandante della divisione pubblica un rapporto
in cui dice quali reparti si sono distinti
quali ufficiali si sono segnalati per imprese valorose
sprezzo del pericolo
Mark Bloch viene citato quattro volte per atti di valore
ci tiene così tanto, per questo lo dico anch'io
ci tiene così tanto che nel suo testamento
redatto in tutt'altra epoca
durante la resistenza
nel suo testamento Bloch dice
al mio funerale
voglio che siano lette le mie quattro citazioni
se si potranno trovare
perché voi capite in quel momento
la gente aveva altro per la testa
siccome noi siamo molto lontani da quel mondo
giusto per ricordarci cosa voleva dire
aver fatto quattro anni di guerra
vi leggo un brano scelto non dico a caso
ma quasi, ce ne sarebbero tanti
anzi ne avevo messi tanti all'inizio
poi li ho sforbiciati perché altrimenti stiamo qua fino domattina
ma ve ne leggo uno
dai ricordi di guerra di Bloch
quando la pallottola colpisce il cranio
da una determinata angolatura
lo fa esplodere
in questo modo morì il mio amico lui
metà del volto pendeva come un'imposta scardinata
e si vedeva all'interno della scatola cranica
quasi vuota
con un asciugamano
ricoprì quell'orribile ferita
volevo nasconderla ai miei soldati
i contadini e gli operai
considerati dei duri
spesso sono particolarmente impressionabili
da parte mia
sopporto senza troppa difficoltà
difficoltà gli spettacoli cruenti
allora nel 1918 finisce la guerra
il capitano Bloch è smobilitato
proviamo a ragionare su che cosa si riporta dalla guerra
dal punto di vista fisico si riporta una salute compromessa
è stato ferito due volte
vabbè leggermente
dopo cinque mesi in trincea si è preso il tifo
ha rischiato di morire di tifo
ha fatto mesi in ospedale
poi è tornato in trincea
e si riporta un'artrite alle mani
che si porterà dietro per tutta la vita
e che gli dà molte difficoltà
quando fa la cosa più importante del suo mestiere
cioè scrivere
tenete conto che quella è un'epoca
in cui si scrive tutto a mano
vabbè quella è un'epoca
l'ho ancora fatto io
i miei primi libri
prima del computer
si scriveva tutto a mano
poi si batteva a macchina una stesura
poi si correggeva
ma la prima stesura a mano
Bloch per tutta la vita scriverà
avendo nelle dita l'artrite
che si è portato dietro dalle trincee delle fiandre
ma questo è il meno
Bloch in guerra
si è guardato intorno
e ha imparato un po' di cose
che gli interessano per il suo mestiere di storico
per esempio ha imparato
che cosa fragile è la memoria umana
a un certo punto si è messo lì
anche lui scrive naturalmente
dicevamo ieri che Salvemini
è stato due settimane in trincea
e voleva già scrivere un libro
perché gli sembrava così importante
trasmettere queste esperienze
Bloch ha poi scritto i suoi ricordi di guerra
ma si è accorto quasi subito
che non si ricordava mica bene
il primo giorno che siamo stati al fuoco
sotto la mitraglia
abbiamo visto i primi morti
lui dice sì certo che li ho i ricordi
alcune immagini anche vivide
però separate
come fotogrammi di un film
montati a casaccio
non riesco più a ricostruire il filo completo
ma allora che roba è la nostra memoria
se è una cosa così importante
me la ricordo male
e nasce un problema
che per lo storico è fondamentale
perché noi
tante volte quando ricostruiamo gli avvenimenti
su cosa ci fondiamo
sui ricordi
che la gente ha scritto
e delle testimonianze
di chi c'era
ecco il professor Bloch scopre
che non ci si può fidare
delle testimonianze
non è soltanto perché uno ti dice
è successo questo
era così e così
certe volte
certe volte le testimonianze
sono molto precise nei particolari
c'era il sole
Bloch analizzando
discutendo con i soldati
vedendo cosa ricordano
si accorge di una cosa
che all'inizio gli sembra pazzesca
sono proprio i particolari
che sono inaffidabili
in dieci persone
giurano che quel giorno
c'era il sole
e invece lui sa che pioveva
e a Bloch viene da dire
non siamo solo noi storici
che abbiamo questo problema
c'è un'altra professione
che ha lo stesso problema nostro
e sono i magistrati
lo storico è come il giudice istruttore
che legge le carte
interroga i testimoni
e deve cercare di ricostruire
una verità
e guai a lui
se crede a tutti quelli
che gli parlano
nasce tutto il tema
della psicologia
della testimonianza
che nel lavoro dello storico
è fondamentale
e Bloch per tutta la vita
penserà noi siamo
come i giudici istruttori
vi racconto anche questa
tanto per capire
no per capire
per vedere come è facile
fra intendersi fra esseri umani
Bloch ha un amico carissimo
con cui litiga continuamente
che è un altro grande storico francese
Lucien Fevre
insieme fondano
la celeberrima rivista Annale
di cui parleremo
a un certo punto
Bloch dice a Fevre
questa cosa
che lui ha sempre pensato
noi siamo come giudici istruttori
Fevre
legge solo la prima parola
giudici
e si arrabbia
dice ma come?
ma noi storici abbiamo sempre detto
che noi non dobbiamo giudicare
non è il nostro compito
giudicare
noi dobbiamo descrivere
cosa è successo
gli manda una letteraccia
e Bloch risponde
ma non intendevo mica dire quello
leggi tutto
il giudice
istruttore
che conduce un'inchiesta
però Fevre
insomma litigano
tanto per cambiare
dopodiché Bloch
aveva perfettamente ragione
a me è capitato
di parlare
con giudici istruttori
che mi hanno detto
l'ho sempre pensato
noi facciamo lo stesso mestiere
in un certo senso
Bloch si accorge
facendo la guerra
anche di un'altra cosa
è strano
come la gente
in certe circostanze
specialmente nelle circostanze
estreme della guerra
si convince
di certe cose
che non stanno
né in cielo
né in terra
tra i soldati
dice Bloch
girano delle notizie
assurde
e tutti ci credono
questa cosa
comincia a interessargli
parecchio
alla fine della guerra
tornato nel suo studio
ci ragiona su
e scrive un famoso saggio
la guerra
e le false notizie
dove analizza proprio
com'è che succede
questa cosa
a un certo punto
tutti cominciano a ripetere
che è successa
una certa cosa
tu vai a vedere
non è vero niente
ma com'è che succede
lui racconta un episodio
che è successo a lui
a un certo punto
sono in un posto
vicino a una cittadina
che si chiama Bren
a un certo punto
catturano un prigioniero tedesco
lui lo interroga
perché lui sa il tedesco
ha studiato anche in Germania
e viene fuori
che questo soldato tedesco
è un riservista
anzianotto
che da civile
faceva il commerciante
a Brema
nota città della Germania
Brema
che in francese
si dice
Brem
lì accanto
c'è la cittadina
di Bren
dopo qualche settimana
Bloch
sente i suoi soldati
che dicono
questi tedeschi
sono gente incredibile
erano preparatissimi
alla guerra
avevano piazzato
spie
dappertutto
pensate
perfino qua
vicino a noi
a Bren
prima della guerra
c'era un tedesco
che stava lì
faceva fitte
di fare il commerciante
in realtà era una spia
e Bloch
indaga
semplicemente
questa cosa
del tedesco
di Brema
i soldati
hanno sentito
questa voce
hanno confuso
il nome
ma non hanno
solo confuso
il nome
Bloch dice
ma perché ci credono
tutti
e scopre
una cosa fondamentale
ci credono
perché corrisponde
a quello che si aspettavano
loro sono ossessionati
dalle spie
spie tedesche
dappertutto
i tedeschi
sono bravissimi
e pericolosissimi
quando una cosa
quadra
con i tuoi pregiudizi
ci credi
ora questo
vuole anche dire
notate
vuol dire
porsi delle domande
che gli storici
prima non si ponevano
vuol dire
qui non stiamo discutendo
sui fatti
Bloch sta ragionando
sulla psicologia collettiva
come pensa la gente
è un problema
storico
uno dei
grandi libri
di Mark Bloch
il primo che scrive
dopo la guerra
si intitola
i re taumaturghi
ed è la storia
di una credenza
collettiva
in passato
la gente
credeva
che i re di Francia
potessero curare
una certa malattia
la scrofola
toccando i malati
e regolarmente
ma fino all'ottocento
i re di Francia
inscenavano
queste cerimonie
in cui venivano
i malati
e il re
li toccava
e poi c'era sempre
qualcuno
che diceva
di essere guarito
prima di Bloch
gli storici
dicono
vabbè
è una superstizione
popolare
chi se ne frega
a noi non interessa
e invece a Bloch
interessa
e come
come funzionano
come pensa
la gente
come è la mentalità
ecco oggi
noi per noi
dire storia
della mentalità
sembra una cosa ovvia
la gente
in passato
non pensava
come noi
pensava in un altro modo
ma studiarlo
i primi a cui è venuto in mente
sono Bloch
e quelli della sua generazione
ultima
la faccio lunga
sì la faccio troppo lunga
pazienza
l'ultima cosa
che Bloch impara
dalla guerra
è il contatto
col popolo francese
voi capite
l'intellettuale parigino
privilegiato
in guerra
incontra i contadini
i minatori
fin dal primo momento
non solo fra i soldati
perché voi sapete
che all'inizio
della prima guerra mondiale
i francesi
stavano perdendo
i tedeschi
hanno invaso
la Francia
poi all'ultimo momento
i francesi
con la battaglia
della Marna
hanno salvato
la situazione
ma intanto
i tedeschi
erano dentro
la guerra
si è combattuta
tutta sul suolo
francese
e Bloch
ricorda
nei primi giorni
di guerra
questo effetto
di vedere
i profughi
dalle zone
invase
e lui dice
questi contadini
di Francia
in fuga
davanti
a un nemico
da cui
non potevamo
proteggerli
e qui c'è anche
tutto il senso
di colpa
del militare
che sta perdendo
la guerra
e che si sente
responsabile
verso una popolazione
civile
che non può
proteggere
da quel momento
Bloch comincia
a guardare
il popolo
i contadini
gli operai
suo figlio
sempre Etienne
che citerò spesso
perché da lui
abbiamo imparato
un sacco di cose
Etienne dice
mio padre
quando eravamo
in campagna
si chiudeva
nel suo studio
e non si poteva
disturbarlo
a meno che non ci fosse
un contadino
del posto
che voleva parlare
con lui
se c'era un contadino
che voleva parlare
con lui
mio padre
c'era sempre
era molto consapevole
dice Etienne
mio padre
era molto consapevole
di essere un privilegiato
e aveva
una grandissima
ammirazione
per quelli
che non avevano
studiato
e però
sapevano ragionare
e sapevano vedere il mondo
con la loro testa
ora questo vuol dire
scoprire anche qui
a guardare il mondo
con altri occhi
i contadini
chi sono
cosa pensano
e il loro lavoro
cos'è il loro lavoro
blocchia il primo storico
che va in giro
per la campagna
guarda i campi
e dice
guarda che strano
in Normandia
i campi sono piccoli
e tutti cintati
da siepi
e invece
in Piccardia
sono tutti aperti
a strisce lunghe
lunghe lunghe lunghe
perché
cosa vuol dire
come lavorano
questi contadini
e con che attrezzi
lavorano
com'è l'aratro
di un contadino medievale
e quando è che cambia
e cosa vuol dire
lavorare con quella roba lì
sono tutte domande
che oggi
oggi ci sembrano ovvie
perché oggi
noi passiamo la vita
a studiare anche queste cose
ma prima
sapete la vecchia cosa
che la storia
si occupa dei re
delle battaglie
ecco
prima non c'era
questo sguardo sul mondo
capite che stagione
sta vivendo
la storiografia
e Bloch
è un protagonista
di questo rinnovamento
appena finita la guerra
si apre un mondo nuovo
c'è la pace
gli danno la cattedra
all'università
una nuova università
a Strasburgo
nell'Alsazia
recuperata
dove la Francia
per prima cosa
chiude l'università tedesca
rispedisce in Germania
tutti i professori tedeschi
e apre una nuova
università francese
chiamando i giovani
più in gamba
fra cui
il professor Bloch
Bloch va a Strasburgo
la terra dei suoi avi
va anche a dare un'occhiata
al villaggio
da dove venivano
i suoi antenati ebrei
forse è la prima volta
che gli viene in mente
questa cosa
degli antenati ebrei
una curiosità interessante
Bloch lavora a Strasburgo
quasi tutta la vita
dei vent'anni
fra il 19
e il 39
fra una guerra e l'altra
ne passa 17
a Strasburgo
solo alla fine
lo chiamano a Parigi
e a Strasburgo
nel 1929
Marc Bloch
e Lucien Fevre
pubblicano
la rivista
il primo numero
della rivista
che è diventata
leggendaria
nel nostro mestiere
le Annale
Annale d'histoire
économique
e sociale
la chiamano
quello che vogliono fare
è una rivista
che esprima
tutto quello
che c'è di nuovo
nella storiografia
e che fino a quel momento
nessuno
a cui nessuno
dava importanza
la storia economica
che vuol dire
prezzi
moneta
lavoro
oggi si parla
di scuola delle Annale
è diventato un modo
di dire
una cosa quasi mitica
come se fosse stato
un gruppo
in realtà non è un gruppo
è una rivista
che pubblica di tutto
che chiede a tutti
dei contributi
purché ci sia
una visione nuova
del mestiere di storico
lo storico deve essere
deve essere economista
anche appunto
perché deve sapere
di prezzi
di salari
di moneta
deve essere sociologo
perché deve sapere
come si comportano
i diversi gruppi sociali
deve saper distinguere
un imprenditore
da un operaio
deve essere antropologo
lo storico
perché deve conoscere
le credenze
appunto
le false credenze
i riti
i miti
basta con le discipline
separate
bisogna cucirle
bisogna far cadere
le barriere
il medioevo
che roba è questo medioevo
noi ci siamo arrivati
ancora neanche adesso
all'università
a far cadere questa cosa
c'è il medioevo
l'età moderna
l'età contemporanea
ma i bloc
e i fevr
sanno
quanto c'è di falso
in queste barriere
e allora
mi fermo ancora
un attimo
solo un attimo
su questo rinnovamento
della storiografia
che vi sto raccontando
troppo in fretta
ma vado come dire
a campionatura
cosa vuol dire
quando vi dico
che bloc è uno
che si pone
delle domande nuove
che nessuno storico
prima si era posto
vi leggo
da una lettera
di mark bloc
al suo complice
lucien fevre
mi sto occupando
di alimentazione
ho solo paura
che l'argomento
mi appassioni troppo
perché è appassionante
avete mai pensato
al problema
delle marmellate
avete dei dati
non penso
alle confetture
di lusso
penso alle marmellate
che sono
un rito borghese
è una parte importante
dell'alimentazione
invernale
tutti fanno
le marmellate
in casa
a quell'epoca
ma marmellata
vuol dire
zucchero
qui mi fermo
un attimo
per farvi capire
qual è il ragionamento
di bloc
lo zucchero
da quando è
che non costa niente
lo zucchero
dall'ottocento
quando hanno scoperto
le barbabietole
prima lo zucchero
si importava
dalle indie
c'era solo
lo zucchero
di canna
ed era costosissimo
dunque bloc
dice
le nonne
fanno la marmellata
certo
ma da quando
le marmellate
della nonna
sì
ma della trisavola
no
perché al tempo
della trisavola
non c'era lo zucchero
in casa
della gente
a voi
potrà venire
da dire
che esagerava
ma bloc
conclude
questa lettera
dicendo
ecco
una grande
rivelazione
del tutto
dimenticata
dalle nostre
povere
storie
di Francia
le quali
si affannano
a dire
quando è morto
Luigi XVI
e quando è stato
abolito
l'editto
di Nantes
ma quando
i francesi
hanno cominciato
a farsi
la marmellata
in casa
non lo dicono
e invece
è importante
anche quello
ancora un esempio
Etienne
ci dice
papà
adorava
il cinema
e non
se ne
vergognava
notate
come cambiano
i tempi
quando ero
bambino io
gli intellettuali
snobbavano
la televisione
adesso la televisione
ovviamente
viene studiata
ai tempi
di bloc
negli anni
20 e 30
gli intellettuali
snobbavano
il cinema
ma il figlio
dice mio papà
adorava il cinema
e non lo nascondeva
non se ne vergognava
ma faceva
anche di peggio
lettera di
Marc Bloch
a Lucien Fevre
sogno
di chiedere
un articolo
sul cinema
per le annal
capite
per una rivista
di storia
non rida
si sono dati
del lei
per tutta la vita
questi due
collaboratori
amici
intimi
non rida
quel che penso
è che il cinema
è uno dei fenomeni
più curiosi
del nostro tempo
la nascita
dell'industria
il passaggio
da una scoperta
scientifica
a uno spettacolo
industrializzato
poi dice
pensate questa rivoluzione
per cui la gente
va al cinema
tutti
negli anni 30
tutti andavano al cinema
continuamente
tutta gente
che prima
non andava mica
a teatro
e adesso
vanno al cinema
è una rivoluzione
anche quella
poi nascono
nuovi mestieri
e i soldi
chi li mette
selvaggina
per noi
dice Bloch
veramente
ecco
non gli è ancora
venuto in mente
l'orco delle fiabe
ma ragiona
già da cacciatore
che va in giro
a guardare
cosa c'è da acchiappare
a noi interessa
tutto
adesso io vorrei
fermarmi brevemente
ad accennarvi
alcuni aspetti
della vita
di Mark Bloch
durante quei
vent'anni
in cui ha fatto
il suo mestiere
perché Mark Bloch
ha fatto il professore
universitario
e lo studioso
a tempo pieno
per vent'anni
19-39
due guerre mondiali
sono pochi
io sono più di 30 anni
che faccio questo mestiere
già adesso
sono incredibilmente
pochi quei vent'anni
vi voglio raccontare
qualcosa
del modo di vita
di Mark Bloch
in quell'epoca
perché anche questa
è ormai
storia
quel genere di vita
di un agiato
professore universitario
degli anni
venti e trenta
oggi non esiste più
ed è
selvaggina
per noi
per l'appunto
allora
Bloch naturalmente
nel 19
oltre a avere
la cattedra
si è sposato
ha sposato
una bella ragazza
anche lei
di una famiglia ebraica
Simone
Simone Vidal
più giovane
di lui
ricchissima
cosa che non guasta
grande famiglia
di petrolieri
ed è un matrimonio
felicissimo
e fanno
sei figli
matrimonio felicissimo
ovviamente
come dire
ci sono soldi
questa è una famiglia
dell'alta borghesia
una famiglia
oggi ci siamo dimenticati
cosa vuol dire
vuol dire
tre persone di servizio
fisse in casa
la cuoca
la domestica
e la babysitter
vuol dire avere
la macchina
negli anni trenta
loro fanno dei viaggi
in macchina
in Inghilterra
in Italia
vuol dire
la casa di campagna
fondamentale
in un mondo
in cui
tra la città
e la campagna
c'è un tale distacco
un conto è vivere in città
poi quando vai in campagna
ci vogliono due giorni
per arrivarci
anche con la macchina
attraverso queste stradine
in questo posticino
sperduto
dove bloc si fa mettere
il telefono
ed è il secondo telefono
del paese
il primo
è al posto pubblico
il telefono
del professor bloc
nel paesino di Fougère
ha il seguente numero
due
la casa di campagna
è fondamentale
per lo stile di vita
di un intellettuale
di allora
perché vuol dire
che passi tutta l'estate
in campagna
i ragazzi giocano
la mamma cucina
ma ci sono tre persone
di servizio
e il professor bloc
ricorda suo figlio
in campagna
dopo colazione
papà si chiudeva
nello studio
che era in un
fabbricato a parte
e ricompariva
all'ora di pranzo
lavorava tutta la mattina
sono i famosi momenti
in cui non bisognava
disturbarlo
a meno che non venisse
un contadino
che voleva parlare con lui
poi dopo pranzo
c'era il caffè
dice Etienne
che per papà
era una specie di rito
anzi per noi figli
arrivati a una certa età
essere ammessi
a partecipare
al rito del caffè
era una specie di promozione
poi
poi tornava
a chiudersi in studio
e lavorava
tutto il pomeriggio
e ricompariva
soltanto per la cena
quindi uno va in campagna
tutta l'estate
e lavora
non deve far lezione
c'è il telefono
che è già uno sbaglio
ma insomma
a parte quello
lavori
sono i momenti
in cui davvero
studi
scrivi
e Simone
la moglie
e la moglie
fa trovare pronto il pranzo
e fa trovare pronta
la cena
è un modo di vita
che appunto
non esiste più
in questi termini
ma c'è ben altro
Etienne
ricorda
e
come dire
ascoltate fino in fondo
prima di scandalizzarvi
perché può sembrare scandaloso
a un certo punto di vista
Simone batte a macchina
tutto ciò che scrive
il marito
perché bisogna battere a macchina
è una corvea
spesso più di una volta
Etienne dice
mia mamma batteva a macchina
tutto
il che vuol dire
che leggeva per prima
tutto quello
che mio padre scriveva
e mio padre
non ha mai pubblicato
una riga
senza prima
averlo discusso
con mia madre
ora io
queste coppie
io le ho ancora viste
lo dico
come dire
è una cosa soggettiva
vabbè non importa
ma è davvero
un modo di vita
sparito
ma che io ho ancora visto
nella generazione
dei miei maestri
storici
che ormai sono morti
ma che sono nati
nel 14
o nel 15
sono vissuti
fino all'inizio del 2000
lì c'erano queste coppie
erano normali
il marito
studioso
e la moglie
che gli batteva
la macchina le cose
correggeva le bozze
con lui
sapeva tutto quello
che studiava
e il marito
sarebbe stato
totalmente perduto
senza la moglie
e in questo rapporto
squilibrato
rispetto ai nostri
criteri di oggi
però erano matrimoni
fortissimi
con una dipendenza
reciproca
e un amore reciproco
Etienne dice
era evidente
che mio padre
e mia madre
erano innamorati
non ho mai saputo
quanto
fino a dopo la guerra
quando trova
le carte
del padre
scopre
che il padre
negli anni peggiori
che stiamo per raccontare
poi della clandestinità
della resistenza
il padre
si mette a scrivere
poesie
dedicate
alla moglie
in cui ricorda
la prima notte
in cui al buio
hanno fatto l'amore
o
le dice
scusami
se questa nostra giornata
insieme
finirà prima della sera
perché da come
si sta mettendo
rischia di finire
prima del tempo
ovviamente i figli
non potevano sospettare
niente
figurati
le poesie d'amore
sulla prima notte
in cui abbiamo fatto
l'amore
ai figli
non si dice niente
Etienne dice
mio padre era severissimo
noi non immaginavamo
niente
della sua interiorità
allora
allora si usava così
poi ci sono anche
altre cose
perché
quando poi
il professor Bloch
come racconteremo
fra poco
parte per una seconda guerra
e i figli
sono ormai
già grandicelli
vanno a aprire
finalmente
di nascosto
il famoso armadio
chiuso a chiave
nella biblioteca
del padre
e nel famoso armadio
chiuso a chiave
Etienne Bloch
dice con un certo divertimento
e anche un pizzico
di fierezza
era la stessa cosa
del famoso
infer
il famoso inferno
della biblioteca nazionale
a Parigi
cioè il reparto
dei libri erotici
mio padre
era un grande lettore
di libri erotici
noi figli
mai e poi mai
avremmo potuto
sospettarlo
ma mentre il papà
è in guerra
gli altarini
si scoprono
ultima cosa
quello che ricorda
Etienne
dello stile di vita
di suo padre
ricordate
si chiude in studio
e lavora tutto il giorno
mio padre aveva
l'ansia di non perdere tempo
aveva la sensazione
che uno deve lavorare
e non può permettersi
di fermarsi
esagerava anche
noi ragazzi
sentivamo le canzonette
alla radio
mio padre si scocciava
non bisogna perdere tempo
a sentire questa robaccia
giocare a carte
in compenso
leggeva libri gialli
il professor Bloch
Agatha Christie
all'epoca
giovane
e in piena attività
li leggeva
in inglese
e così diceva
a se stesso
che in fondo
era per uno scopo utile
perché così
migliorava il suo inglese
imparava a conoscerli
in Inghilterra
di fatto
dice Etienne
papà adorava i gialli
tanto che a un certo punto
gli è venuto in mente
di scrivere
un giallo
anche lui
abbiamo trovato
fra le sue carte
c'era tutto il progetto
la trama
i personaggi
poi non ha fatto in tempo
a scriverlo
cosa daremmo noi oggi
noi del mestiere
almeno per avere un giallo
scritto da Mark Bloch
in ogni caso però
vedete che comunque
c'è qualcosa
che non stupisce
perché un giallo
vuol dire
comunque
la storia
di come si scopre
la verità
alla fine
arrivi sempre a quello
scoprire la verità
bene
fin qua
tutto bene
in apparenza
vent'anni
di vita familiare
felice
di grande produttività
rivoluzionano
la storiografia mondiale
benissimo
ma sono gli anni venti
e poi soprattutto
gli anni trenta
negli anni trenta
nessun europeo
può vivere
specialmente un intellettuale
che sa cosa succede
al mondo
nessun europeo
vive la sua vita
tranquilla
senza sentire
che sta salendo
qualche cosa
di molto brutto
e senza un senso
di angoscia crescente
per quello
che si vede
arrivare
Bloch lo scopre
per prima cosa
quando si accorge
che il suo cognome
dopo tutto
vuol dire
qualche cosa
lo scopre lentamente
vi racconto ancora
questo aspetto
entro un po'
nel dettaglio
per capirci
Bloch è a Strasburgo
dopo un po'
si secca
un professore francese
deve tornare a Parigi
se vuole che la sua carriera
sia veramente riuscita
comincia a trafficare
come tutti noi
per il trasferimento
a Parigi
è molto ambizioso
il meglio
che c'è a Parigi
non è la Sorbona
è il Collège
il Collège de France
il Collège
è una istituzione
meravigliosa
dove una cinquantina
di studiosi
di altissimo livello
di tutte le discipline
sono pagati
profumatamente
per studiare
quello che vogliono
con l'unico obbligo
di fare una volta
alla settimana
una lezione
per il grande pubblico
una lezione come questa
non lezioni universitarie
quindi specialistiche
ma una lezione
per tutti
a Parigi
chiunque può andare
sedersi nella sala
del Collège
e arrivano i più grandi
intellettuali di Francia
a parlargli
delle loro cose
Bloch vorrebbe
andare al Collège
il suo amico Fevre
ci è riuscito
Bloch ci prova
si candida
diverse volte
il Collège
è un'istituzione
che si gestisce
da solo
per cooptazione
quando muore uno
i sopravvissuti
votano
chi chiamare
quindi bisogna fare
delle telefonate
muovere delle amicizie
insomma tutta roba
che è normale
nel nostro mestiere
e
e Bloch ci prova
una volta
e una seconda volta
e una terza volta
e ogni volta
non ce la fa
c'è qualcuno
che gli dice
ma sai
è per il tuo cognome
ci sono già
troppi ebrei
nel Collège
e c'è tanta gente
che pensa
che sono troppi
e che non bisogna
chiamarne altri
e lì Bloch
è la prima volta
che a un certo punto
scrive
lui
a questa corrispondenza
con Fevre
lui è rimasto a Strasburgo
l'altro è a Parigi
per nostra fortuna
così si scrivono
e noi abbiamo le lettere
e lì Bloch
a un certo punto
dice sì
è proprio vero
qui l'antisemitismo
sta tornando
nel nostro paese
l'antisemitismo
e di fronte a questo
Bloch
per la prima volta
comincia a dirsi
ma dunque
io sono ebreo
chi ci aveva mai pensato
e invece è vero
sono ebreo
che ci devo fare
con questa scoperta
sono ebreo
scrive a un certo punto
a Fevre
se non per la religione
è che non pratico
come non ne pratico
nessuna
almeno per nascita
non ne traggo
né orgoglio
né vergogna
perché sono
spero
abbastanza buono storico
da sapere
che le predisposizioni
razziali
sono un mito
stamattina
il nostro amico
Guido Barbujani
ci ha confermato
la stessa cosa
dal punto di vista
della scienza
di oggi
non rivendico mai
la mia origine
tranne
quando mi trovo
davanti
a un antisemita
quando mi trovo
davanti
a un antisemita
allora divento
ebreo
effettivamente
ma non è solo
l'antisemitismo
che nella Francia
di quegli anni
potrebbe sembrare
un problema privato
il problema è
regge questa democrazia
o verrà la dittatura
in Italia
c'è già la dittatura
a un certo punto
c'è una lettera
in cui Bloch dice
di questo passo
ci faranno finire
come Matteotti
e non è molto bello
vedere che l'Italia
offriva questo tipo
di esempio
a chi la guardava
dalla Francia
e poi nel 33
la dittatura
arriva anche in Germania
dall'altra parte
del Reno
Strasburgo
e lì c'è il confide
e dall'altra parte
sfilano le camice brune
e nella corrispondenza
di Mark Bloch
si sente appunto
questa cosa
che dicevo prima
questa sensazione
di chi vive
in un'epoca
che sta diventando
molto brutta
e si accorge
che sta arrivando
qualcosa di spaventoso
e non sa bene
cosa può fare
a un certo punto
racconta
vuoi un segno
dei tempi
dice
mio ultimo figlio
Jean Paul
sei anni
lo vedo
che gioca
con i soldatini
francesi e tedeschi
e naturalmente
fanno la guerra
e Jean Paul
ne alza uno
e mi dice
papà
guarda qui
Hitler
perfino i bambini
di sei anni
sanno che c'è Hitler
e che verrà la guerra
tra la Francia
e la Germania
prima o poi
in Francia
il clima politico
è pesantissimo
nel 34
ci sono manifestazioni
di piazza
della destra
che rovesciano
il governo
e molti hanno paura
di essere a un passo
dalla marcia su Roma
dalla marcia su Parigi
dal colpo di stato fascista
Fevra
in una lettera
di quei giorni
scrive
nei licei
si compra una pistola
per 10 franchi
allora
come reagiscono
questi uomini
come reagisce
Mark Bloch
di fronte
a queste cose
e soprattutto
che idee politiche
ha Mark Bloch
suo figlio
Etienne
provate a indovinare
secondo voi
ne parlava
ai figli
non ne parlava
per niente
Etienne dice
secondo me
mio padre
non so quali erano
le sue idee politiche
credo di poter dire
che era un uomo
di sinistra
ma era altrettanto
un uomo
d'ordine
e se voi pensate
chi sono
questi uomini
è gente
che non fa politica
perché non l'ha mai fatta
perché sono grandi
borghesi
ricchi
il loro ceto
è tutto
di destra
anche il cognato
ebreo
che però è un petroliere
e che magari
finirà ad Auschwitz
però in quel momento
non ci pensa mica
al fatto che lui è ebreo
è un petroliere
un grande industria
sono tutti di destra
nel loro mondo
però questi
sono storici
e hanno troppa curiosità
hanno troppa voglia
di scoprire la verità
hanno troppa capacità
di non credere
alla propaganda
anzi hanno orrore
della propaganda
faccio una piccola
anticipazione
quando scoppia
la seconda guerra mondiale
bloc è richiamato
e c'è l'ipotesi
che lo mandino
all'ufficio propaganda
dell'esercito
ci starebbe benissimo
bloc scrive a fevre
tutto ma non
alla propaganda
avrei orrore
di un lavoro
nella propaganda
bisogna che gli storici
abbiano le mani pulite
in altre parole
con le bugie
neanche a fin di bene
ci si può mescolare
e dunque
il loro mondo
è tutto di destra
loro però
sono gente che ragiona
che non crede alla propaganda
non sono comunisti
assolutamente
perché hanno orrore
del dogmatismo
anche qui
piccola parentesi
spero che non diventi
difficile seguire
c'è una lettera
di bloc in cui parla
di un articolo
per la rivista
per le annal
che va fatto riscrivere
perché l'autore
è troppo dogmatico
afferma le cose
con troppa sicurezza
e bloc dice a fevre
glielo ridì
all'articolo
all'autore
glielo faccia riscrivere
gli ricordi
in caso di bisogno
che il dogma
è al suo posto
in un bollettino
parrocchiale
meno nelle annal
e dunque
non sono certamente
comunisti
ma hanno il senso
dei movimenti popolari
delle ingiustizie
sociali
bloc a un certo punto
arriva a dire
marx doveva essere
un tipo insopportabile
come filosofo
non credo che fosse
un granché
però quando dice
proletari di tutto
il mondo
unitevi
lo storico
vede che c'è
qualcosa
di vero
in questo
risultato
a un certo punto
bloc e i suoi amici
si accorgono
che agli occhi
del loro mondo
dell'editore
dell'annal
che è un grande
imprenditore
loro sono
dei rossi
perché quel mondo
si deve stare
da una parte
in quegli anni
si deve stare
da una parte
o dall'altra
se non sei
tutto schierato
con l'esercito
con il nazionalismo
ecco allora
allora sei un rosso
sei uno pericoloso
e cosa fare?
firmano appelli
che non sanno bene
cos'altro fare
comitato di vigilanza
degli intellettuali
antifascisti
firmano
appello ai lavoratori
lo leggono
fra loro si dicono
quante fregnacce
in questo appello
come scritto
però cosa vuoi fare
lo firmiamo
e non fanno altro
e insegnano
e studiano
e pubblicano libri
e pubblicano la rivista
e di fronte
ai tempi
che cambiano
si dicono
e adesso cosa succederà?
una lettera di bloc
del 35
non essendo profeta
quando vi dico
che vedono
quello che sta arrivando
e uno non ci crede quasi
lettera del dicembre 35
non essendo profeta
non so dove sarò
nell'agosto 38
voglio dire
in che mondo
e se in questo
sotto che cielo
o magari
in un rifugio
antiaereo
o in un campo
di concentramento
la vita
con i tempi
che corrono
non abbonda
in certezze
altra lettera
del 37
da Londra
è in viaggio a Londra
scopre che
a Londra
Hitler sta simpatico
a tutti
e che l'Inghilterra
farebbe tanto volentieri
un accordo con Hitler
qui è dove si lascia andare
più di tutti
più di tutte le altre lettere
che ho letto
vorrei vedere
impiccare
Mussolini
Hitler
e Laval
che è
il filofascista francese
non succederà
e in fondo
sarebbe una magra
consolazione
uno
nel suo angolino
non vede modo
di far niente
mi scusi
per questi discorsi
inutili
meglio lavorare
penso
ecco
in questo momento
vedremo poi
abbiamo ancora
insomma sì
lo vedremo
che farà in tempo
a dirsi come abbiamo
sbagliato
ma in questo momento
fra le due guerre
Bloch si dice
cosa possiamo fare
lavoriamo
e poi scoppia
la nuova guerra
nel 39
scoppia la seconda
guerra mondiale
e il capitano
Mark Bloch
viene richiamato
per fare la guerra
e potrebbe anche
farsi esentare
perché ormai
ha più di 50 anni
e tiene sei figli
ma non vuole
chiedere l'esonero
e quindi va in guerra
stavolta non va più
in trincea
va nello stato maggiore
di un'armata
scherza
dice devo essere
il capitano più vecchio
dell'esercito francese
lo mettono in un ufficio
all'inizio
gli fanno fare
una cosa che sa fare bene
l'ufficiale di collegamento
con gli alleati inglesi
lui è uno
che sa le lingue
ma gli eserciti
hanno le loro logiche
dopo un po'
lo spostano
lo mettono
a gestire
i rifornimenti
di benzina
di un'armata
per capirci
gestire i rifornimenti
di benzina
di un'armata
vuol dire
che tu sei l'uomo
che deve garantire
che alcune migliaia
di carri armati
e camion
ricevono
trovano ogni giorno
la benzina
che gli serve
nel deposito
che si trova
in quel certo posto
e tu gli hai rilasciato
il buono
con la garanzia
che la benzina
la trovano
e intanto
ne arriva dell'eco
tu devi gestire
tutto questo
blocca all'inizio
dice oddio
speriamo che Hitler
non attacchi subito
perché altrimenti
poi però impara
e si scopre
una cosa
che un po'
già si intuiva
che in realtà
il capitano Bloch
in guerra
si trova
nel suo elemento
e che tutto quello
che comincia a fare
lo fa bene
si impadronisce
di questo meccanismo
e comincia
a piacergli
vanno avanti
per un po'
di mesi
qui vi devo richiamare
vi seguite sempre
ormai siamo arrivati
al 40
vi devo richiamare
l'inizio
della seconda guerra mondiale
sul fronte occidentale
ricordate
la drolle de guerre
la guerra assurda
la finta guerra
cosa è successo
in breve
Hitler ha attaccato
la Polonia
questo lo sappiamo tutti
se l'è mangiata
la Francia
e l'Inghilterra
gli hanno dichiarato
guerra per difendere
la Polonia
però non hanno osato
attaccare
e neanche Hitler
ha attaccato
dal settembre 39
al maggio del 40
questi eserciti
stanno l'uno
di fronte all'altro
praticamente
senza sparare
un colpo
e il capitano
Mark Bloch
mentre gestisce
la sua benzina
annota
come l'umore
dell'esercito
pian piano
si guasta
in questi lunghi
mesi
in cui non sai
non sai
se stai facendo
davvero la guerra
non sai
perché la fai
nell'aprile del 40
in una sua lettera
dice
qui
qui si vive
nella noia
più totale
nell'attesa
di qualche cosa
magari spaventoso
ma che renda
un po' meno
assurda
la nostra esistenza
qui
così sta vivendo
tutto l'esercito
francese
e così vive
tutta la Francia
poi il 10 maggio
i tedeschi
attaccano
e nel giro
di pochi giorni
sbaragliano
l'esercito francese
sfondano il fronte
e invadono
la Francia
e gran parte
dell'esercito francese
compresa l'armata
dove Bloch
è come dice lui
il gran capo
della benzina
si trova circondata
dai tedeschi
e in rotta
in ritirata
frenetica
per arrivare
a un porto
qualunque
e imbarcarsi
per mettersi in salvo
dai tedeschi
che incalzano
arrivano
come sapete tutti
a Dunkirk
dove la flotta inglese
effettivamente
riesce a salvare
e portare
in Inghilterra
gran parte
delle forze inglesi
e francesi
che erano state
circondate
Bloch
è lì
nella ritirata
e più che mai
è nel suo elemento
sapete
era il re della benzina
aveva la mappa
di tutti i depositi
di benzina
dell'armata
adesso che si stanno
ritirando di corsa
con i tedeschi
dietro
qual è il suo compito
con ordini
o senza ordini
bruciare tutto
da Mons a Lille
ho fatto bruciare
a tutti gli incroci
della ritirata
migliaia di ettolitri
di benzina
ho appiccato
più incendi
di quelli
che può
aver appiccato
Attila
dopodiché
a uno storico
capitano strani incontri
sulla spiaggia
di Dunkirk
con i bombardieri
tedeschi
che scendono giù
e tutti lì
che aspettano
di vedere
se si salvano
incontra
un giovane ufficiale
dice ma lei
era un mio studente
certo
professor Bloch
ho appena letto
il suo libro
sulla società feudale
che capolavoro
e stanno lì
a parlare di questo
con gli stuca
che vengono giù
Bloch è nel suo elemento
un collega
un ufficiale di mestiere
gli dice una cosa
che gli fa un piacere enorme
tanto che lui la scrive
nei suoi ricordi
il collega
gli dice
guardi
ci sono dei militari
di mestiere
che non saranno mai
dei guerrieri
e ci sono dei civili
che invece
per natura
sono dei guerrieri
prima del 10 maggio
il giorno
dell'attacco tedesco
non l'avrei mai
immaginato
ma lei
lei è un guerriero
ecco Bloch
sentirsi dire questa cosa
da un ufficiale di mestiere
non è che la guerra
gli piaccia
ma l'avventura
gli piace
e di avventura
ne ha finché si vuole
si imbarca a Dunkerque
lo portano in Inghilterra
sarebbe in salvo
ma il comando francese
non ha mica capito
che la guerra
è perduta
l'intera armata
trasferita in Inghilterra
viene reimbarcata
il giorno dopo
e riportata in Francia
un po' più lontano
in Normandia
con l'idea
di rimetterla in piedi
e continuare la guerra
quindi il professor Bloch
il capitano Bloch
con tutti gli altri
viene reimbarcato
la sera stessa
e il mattino dopo
sbarca di nuovo
in Francia
lì cercano
di rimettere in piedi
l'armata
i tedeschi avanzano
continuamente
dice ogni giorno
ci spostavamo indietro
di 20 chilometri
non abbiamo mica capito
che bisognava spostarsi
di 200 chilometri
non avevamo capito
niente
dice
finalmente un bel giorno
nella città di Rennes
il capitano Bloch
esce dal suo ufficio
attraversa la strada
poi sente un rumore
si volta
e ci sono i tedeschi
che stanno attraversando
la strada
la colonna corazzata tedesca
che è entrata in città
a questo punto
il capitano Bloch
si guarda intorno
poi va all'albergo
no
passa da un conoscente
si fa dare
un abito civile
giacca e cravatta
i pantaloni della divisa
si confondevano
si fa dare
giacca e cravatta
smette l'uniforme
va all'albergo
e prende una stanza
all'albergo
a nome del professor Bloch
di Parigi
non mi hanno mai cercato
i tedeschi
dice
del resto
ne avevano talmente
tanti di prigionieri
non gli importava
già più niente
di prenderne degli altri
e quindi lui
se ne sta per un po'
all'albergo
poi si sposta
in un'altra città
e finalmente
all'inizio di luglio
riesce
a ritrovare la famiglia
che non vede
da un sacco di tempo
ah sì
vedi
dimenticavo
questo
non guardo mai il foglio
vi volevo ancora
raccontare questo
la moglie
lo ha incontrato
durante la ritirata
a un certo punto
e la moglie
lo ha trovato
abbronzato
dimagrito
pieno di energia
convinto
che vinceremo
ancora noi
alla fine
e comunque
dice Bloch
alla moglie
dopo
ci saranno
molti conti
da regolare
emerge
in lui
in mezzo a questo
sfacelo
dell'esercito
francese
e della Francia
una nota
di durezza
di spietatezza
che poi vedremo
ancora
venire fuori
insomma
la moglie
gli dice
meno male
che sei vivo
ti vedevo già
prigioniero
dei tedeschi
e conoscendoti
ti vedevo
che li provocavi
senza motivo
e loro ti fucilavano
invece per fortuna
sei vivo
che fare
una nuova estate
nella casa di campagna
salvo che adesso
la Francia
è invasa
dai tedeschi
e loro sono lì
tagliati fuori
da Parigi
non si sa
cosa sarà il futuro
si campa
da un giorno
all'altro
il personale
di servizio
non c'è più
soldi
ce ne è pochi
questa lunga estate
nella casa di campagna
cosa fa lo storico
scrive
e Bloch
uno dei suoi più
grandi libri
la strana
disfatta
in cui racconta
la guerra
che ha visto
e cerca
di capire
perché la Francia
è stata sbaragliata
in questo modo
è una diagnosi
di malucidità
pazzesca
dice noi eravamo
vecchi e i tedeschi
sono giovani
noi eravamo
comandati
da vegliardi
noi abbiamo
combattuto
una guerra
di altri tempi
una volta
si facevano
le guerre coloniali
e noi col fucile
sconfiggevamo
i neri
armati di zagaglie
qui è stata
la stessa cosa
solo che noi
eravamo quelli
con la zagaglia
e i tedeschi
quelli col fucile
i tedeschi correvano
in macchina
con i motori
e noi non abbiamo
capito niente
di cos'era questa guerra
e poi fa un'analisi
però
mi fermo ancora
un istante su questo
il blocco
che non è certo comunista
anzi
uomo d'ordine
però
però dice
non è possibile
questo paese
come si è spaccato
prima della guerra
c'erano le manifestazioni
degli operai
in piazza
certo
rumorose
piene di rancore
pugni alzati
ostili
ma
c'era anche
così tanta speranza
in questa gente
che manifestava
così tanto candore
e invece
tutta la classe
dirigente francese
si è presa paura
i politici
i militari
il clero
gli industriali
hanno tutti
avuti una tale
paura
che hanno cominciato
a dire
meglio Hitler
piuttosto
che i rossi
e lì
dice bloc
noi ci siamo fregati
la Francia
si è fatta fregare
così
e poi però
naturalmente
siccome è un uomo onesto
dice ed è colpa
anche nostra
è lì che comincia
a dire noi
fra le due guerre
cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo studiato
abbiamo insegnato
ci siamo detti
che era quella
la cosa migliore
che potevamo fare
avevamo talmente
voglia di studiare
dopo la prima guerra mondiale
quattro anni in trincea
abbiamo fatto quello
non abbiamo osato
essere la voce
che grida nel deserto
che all'inizio
è nel deserto
magari dopo no
e che comunque
avrà gridato
la sua fede
noi ci siamo chiusi
nei nostri studi
che possano i giovani
perdonarci
il sangue
che abbiamo
sulle mani
e poi dice anche
un'altra cosa bloc
noi storici
in particolare
non abbiamo fatto niente
perché eravamo
talmente abituati
a pensare
che la storia
la fanno le masse
le grandi forze
sotterranee
l'individuo
cosa può fare
c'è qualcuno
che sta male
per caso
no ok
grazie
benissimo
nessun problema
la storia
la fanno le masse
le grandi forze
e l'individuo
non può fare niente
e lì il professor
Mark Block
dice
pensare questo
significava
non aver capito
la storia
non è che non abbiamo capito
il nostro dovere
di cittadini
neanche la storia
abbiamo capito
perché l'individuo
può fare anche
la storia
ci deve stare dentro
e deve fare
non può chiudersi
nello studio
poi a forza di pensarci
dice anche a un certo punto
sempre in una lettera
a Fevre
vabbè senti
è inutile ormai
stare ad avere rimpianti
alla fine
sai che c'è
tutto sommato
avremmo avuto
delle strane vite
e noi che siamo storici
avremmo avuto
anche altre esperienze
oltre
alla ricerca
d'archivio
ma Block
non sa ancora
quali esperienze
sta per fare
io non ho più molto tempo
ma questo ve lo devo raccontare
a tutti i costi
quindi avrete dieci minuti
di pazienza
perché Block
va in clandestinità
a un certo punto
Block è ebreo
in una Francia
occupata dai tedeschi
e per un po'
riesce a continuare
a insegnare
perché in qualche modo
alcuni ebrei
sono esentati
per meriti di guerra
però
spedito
in una piccola università
di provincia
a Parigi
non può tornare
perché lì ci sono i tedeschi
lui è nella Francia
di Vichy
che non è occupata
tecnicamente
nella sua casa
a Parigi
confiscata
ci vanno i tedeschi
la sua biblioteca
a Parigi
messa in scatoloni
e sparisce
in Germania
i figli
la ritroveranno
in parte
dopo la guerra
a Mosca
dove i russi
dalla Germania
se l'erano portata via
quindi lui vive
questi ultimi anni
tenta ancora
insegna
in un clima
di antisemitismo
crescente
e poi
e poi finisce
che anche la Francia
di Vichy
viene occupata
dai tedeschi
e lì
gli stessi dirigenti
locali
della sua università
gli dicono
ma tu che sei ebreo
è meglio
che ti nascondi
cosa fa il professor Bloch
a questo punto
la famiglia
nella casa di campagna
i due figli maggiori
li fa espatriare
in Spagna
da dove spera
che poi riescano
a raggiungere
De Gaulle
e le forze
della Francia libera
in Africa
Etienne
che vi ho citato
prima più di una volta
lo ricorda così
l'ho visto
l'ultima volta
il 18 dicembre
del 42
me lo ricordo male
a Bloch
sarebbe piaciuta
questa cosa
i ricordi
è un'immagine
così vaga
nostro padre
che sparisce
nella scalinata
della stazione
di Perpignan
dove ci aveva
accompagnati
a prendere il treno
per la Spagna
e poi
sistemati così
due figli grandi
il professor Bloch
va a Lione
che è la grande città
più vicina
con i suoi contatti
cerca di contattare
qualcuno della resistenza
finalmente
lo presentano
al leader
di uno dei movimenti
di resistenza
e questo
Georges Altman
capo di un movimento
che si chiama
Le Franc Tireur
il Franco Tiratore
pubblica un giornale
clandestino
fanno molte cose
e Georges Altman
racconta
mi è arrivato
nell'ufficio
questo signore
un gentiluomo
con la legion d'onore
all'occhiello
giacca e cravatta
gli occhialini
il bastone
in una mano
la borsa
nell'altra
poco opulento
e mi ha detto
piacere
io vorrei lavorare
con voi
nella resistenza
dice
all'inizio
sembrava una cosa
così improbabile
dopodiché
lo mettono
alla prova
portare le lettere
portare i giornali
clandestini
scoprono
che è bravissimo
ancora
il professor Bloch
è di nuovo in guerra
per la terza volta
in vita sua
e tanto per cambiare
lo sa fare bene
molto rapidamente
si accorgono
che è bravissimo
e quindi comincia
a fare carriera
all'interno del suo movimento
diventa rapidamente
il rappresentante
del suo movimento
nel direttivo
della resistenza
in tutta la Francia
meridionale
e poi
verso la fine
diventa
provvisoriamente
capo di tutto
il direttivo
della resistenza
non comunista
i comunisti
la fanno per conto loro
in tutta la Francia
meridionale
ha cioè
delle responsabilità
enormi
e ha delle identità
clandestine
ovviamente
ha degli uffici
clandestini
delle segretarie
clandestine
scrivono
pubblicano
tengono
corrispondenza
raccolgono informazioni
mandano ordini
tutto questo
nella città di Lione
dove nel frattempo
a comandare
la Gestapo
è arrivato
un ufficiale
che si chiama
Klaus Barbie
e che diventerà
poi famoso
perché lo processeranno
solo tanti anni dopo
e che sarà
soprannominato
il boia di Lione
mentre la Gestapo
di Klaus Barbie
cerca di annientare
la resistenza
Bloch
fa di tutto
e le testimonianze
ci dicono
era bravissimo
prima che arrivasse lui
era un tale caos
non funzionava niente
lui è l'unico
che sapeva organizzare
il lavoro come si deve
era anche l'unico
che non dava del tuo
a nessuno
continua a dare
del lei a tutti
e fa funzionare
le cose
scrive sui giornali
clandestini
ma ancora di più
fa continue ispezioni
nella regione
per contattare
i vari gruppi
col pretesto
di fare ricerche
d'archivio
va in archivio
poi la sera
va a trovare i gruppi
ogni mese
va a Parigi
in segreto
perché non ci
ebrei oltretutto
ogni mese
va segretamente
a Parigi
per partecipare
a riunioni
dato che va a Parigi
ne approfitta
va al cinema
che gli manca
evidentemente
ogni tanto
al ristorante
se ce n'è ancora
qualcuno
che funziona
va a trovare
il suo amico
Lucien Fevre
passa davanti
a casa sua
alla sua ex casa
dove adesso
abitano degli ufficiali
tedeschi
e dove sul
sul balcone
hanno messo
un riflettore
dell'antiaerea
va a trovare
Fevre
e discutono
dopo la guerra
bisognerà
riformare
la scuola
l'università
riformare
no
rivoluzionare
questo paese
deve cambiare
prepara
l'organigramma
del futuro governo
della Francia
perché ai vertici
della resistenza
fanno anche questo
preparano l'insurrezione
quando sbarcheranno
gli americani
in Normandia
dobbiamo essere pronti
tutto pronto
e dopo
quando prenderemo
il potere
dobbiamo avere
tutto pronto
nel frattempo
la moglie ogni tanto
va a trovarlo
dalla casa di campagna
nell'appartamento
clandestino
a Lione
gli porta un cambio
di biancheria
gli porta qualche roba
cucinata
se no
si scrivono
lui scrive continuamente
alla moglie
le lettere sono
come dire
raffigurano
un'alternanza di umori
ci sono i momenti
di speranza
ci sono anche i momenti
di depressione
in cui dice
lo so che ti ho lasciata
lì sola
con i quattro figli
rimasti
ma cosa dovevo fare
e intanto
passano i mesi
passa anche il mio tempo
ma in cinque minuti
finiamo
passano i mesi
e il clima a Lione
si fa sempre più pesante
perché Klaus Barbie
sa fare il suo mestiere
e Bloch si rende conto
di una cosa
non per niente
è uno storico
si rende conto
che lì è una questione
di probabilità
ogni giorno che passa
è più probabile
che mi arrestino
a Fevre confida
ogni tanto
delle premonizioni
di una morte
orribile
l'ultima lettera
alla moglie
la scrive il mattino
dell'otto marzo
del quarantaquattro
le dice
lo so guarda
che sei sui da sola
e ci sono tante decisioni
da prendere
i due figli grandi
sono in Spagna
e ormai stanno raggiungendo
De Gaulle
ma il terzo figlio
è diventato maggiorenne
e vuole andare
con i partigiani
anche lui
bisogna decidere
cosa fargli fare
a questo ragazzo
e Bloch le dice
guarda lo so
lo so che
scusami se sono così lontano
questa lettera
la scrive
la mattina dell'otto marzo
poi esce
mentre è appena uscito
una macchina
della Gestapo
si ferma davanti
al portone di casa
scendono
vanno a prendere
la portinaia
è quel tizio là
che abita al secondo piano
ah sì sì
è appena uscito
è andato di là
gli corrono dietro
e lo arrestano
su un ponte
su uno dei tanti
ponti di Lione
negli stessi giorni
viene arrestata
in pratica
l'intera direzione
regionale
della Resistenza
c'è qualcuno
evidentemente
che ha confessato
sotto tortura
ormai sanno i nomi
io qui ho scoperto
una cosa che non sapevo
ho scoperto tante cose
che non sapevo
tutti nel mio mestiere
sappiamo che Mark Bloch
è un eroe della Resistenza
ma non sapevo
quanto era importante
la stampa di Vichy
annuncia
la Resistenza
a Lione
è distrutta
il capo
dei terroristi
era un ebreo
Mark Bloch
aveva preso
come pseudonimo
Narbonne
che è una città
francese del sud
i giornali di Vichy
sanno e scrivono
il capo
della Resistenza
era un ebreo
che aveva preso
come nome
di guerra
il nome
di una città
francese del sud
i tedeschi
sono ancora più espliciti
il Völkischer
Beobachter
il giornale
il quotidiano
del partito nazista
si occupa
dell'arresto
di Bloch
un ebreo
dirigeva
i terroristi
in Francia
l'ambasciatore tedesco
a Vichy
Abetz
scrive
al ministero degli esteri
a Berlino
dicendo
il capo
della direzione
del movimento
di resistenza
a Lione
era un ebreo
francese
chiamato
Bloch
ecco
io onestamente
non lo sapevo
che
ai più alti vertici
dello stato nazista
la cattura
di Mark Bloch
fosse stata
celebrata
come un grande successo
dopodiché
cosa succede
che lo portano
al quartiere generale
della Gestapo
a casa
di Klaus Barbie
quello che succede
a Bloch
noi lo sappiamo
dal diario
di un capo
della resistenza
che è rimasto libero
e che via via
annotava le cose
che veniva a sapere
14 marzo
lo storico
Mark Bloch
è stato arrestato
a Lione
20 marzo
Mark Bloch
è stato visto
in un corridoio
il viso
tumefatto
e insanguinato
qualche tempo dopo
a Lione
Mark Bloch
è stato torturato
immersioni
nell'acqua gelida
bruciature
dalla pianta
dei piedi
tre costole rotte
è appena uscito
da una bronco
polmonite
perché naturalmente
con l'immersione
in acqua gelida
ti prendi la bronco
polmonite
dopodiché
la Gestapo
ti riporta
in infermeria
e ti cura
perché ha ancora
bisogno di interrogarti
è chiuso
nella prigione
di Montluc
a Lione
insieme a centinaia
di altri resistenti
catturati
e poi
il 6 giugno
del 44
gli americani
e gli inglesi
sbarcano in Normandia
è sicuramente
l'ultima notizia
che Mark Bloch
ha fatto in tempo
ad avere
di come stava
andando la guerra
sbarcati gli americani
i tedeschi
si preparano
a evacuare la Francia
e per evacuare la Francia
non si vogliono
lasciare dietro nessuno
cominciano a fucilare
sistematicamente
i prigionieri
di Montluc
un giorno 20
un giorno 50
in tutto
fra giugno
e settembre
vengono uccisi
713 prigionieri
di quella prigione
Mark Bloch
è fra i primi
il 16 giugno
quella sera
ne portano fuori
ammanettati
li caricano
su camionette
li portano fuori città
a un'ora di distanza
in un campo
deserto
li fanno scendere
a gruppi
e li falciano
a raffiche di mitra
Etienne Bloch
il figlio
che è uno molto polemico
dice anche questo
si dice sempre
mio padre è stato
fucilato
che bel eufemismo
uno si immagina
il proto
ecco
li hanno abbattuti
in mezzo a un campo
in piena notte
a raffiche di mitra
ora
in questi casi
in queste fucilazioni
collettive
in piena notte
nel nulla
succedeva abbastanza
spesso
che qualcuno
si salvava
dei 30
portati fuori
con Bloch
due
vengono solo feriti
e poi in qualche modo
riescono a venire fuori
e si salvano
e hanno raccontato
cos'è successo
quindi abbiamo
una testa
uno non ha parlato
non ha detto
non si ricordava niente
l'altro ha testimoniato
uso questa parola
ricordate cosa direbbe
il professor Bloch
una testimonianza
certo
andiamoci piano
dice il superstite
ho sentito
molti compagni
cadere
gridando
addio mamma
oppure addio moglie
oppure viva la Francia
ho saputo dopo
dice questo superstite
che quello lì
che ha detto viva la Francia
era Mark Bloch
professore alla Sorbona
e tutti hanno poi detto
Mark Bloch
è morto
gridando viva la Francia
naturalmente
il professor Bloch
avrebbe detto
ma lui come fa
cos'è sta storia
ho saputo dopo
è solo lui
che c'era lì
da chi altri
l'ha saputo dopo
il professor Bloch
direbbe
ecco le false notizie
come si diffondono
perché uno
se l'aspetta
corrispondono
a chi altri
poteva gridare
viva la Francia
questo non lo sapremo mai
quindi
un'altra cosa
è più probabile
c'è una leggenda
questa è una leggenda
secondo cui
ma che si diffonde
già nel 45
subito
Bloch prima di morire
aveva accanto a sé
un compagno
un ragazzino
un sedicenne
non c'era nessun sedicenne
fra i fucilati di quel giorno
aveva accanto a sé
un ragazzino
che tremava di paura
e il professor Bloch
gli dice
non aver paura
piccolo
non fa male
il figlio Etienne
dice
eh figuriamoci
le leggende
chi può dirlo
in realtà
l'unico superstite
ha detto
una cosa un po' diversa
l'unico superstite
ha detto
hanno portato fuori
dalla camionetta
i primi
abbiamo sentito
le raffiche di Mitra
e Bloch mi ha detto
quel che c'è di buono
è che non si ha
il tempo di soffrire
questa cosa qui
credibile
diventa
fulmineamente
il fatto
che ha rassicurato
il ragazzino
dicendo
non aver paura
non fa male
ecco mi sono dilungato
su questo
perché credo
che a Bloch
avrebbe dato soddisfazione
sapere che la sua morte
è diventata una leggenda
e una fonte
di miti
di questo tipo
che lui si sarebbe divertito
a smontare
ma per chiudere
userò ancora le sue parole
le parole del suo testamento
scritto pochi mesi
prima di morire
chiede funerali civili
però vuole che si lega
un suo testo
al funerale
prima delle famose citazioni
al merito
per le azioni eroiche
nella prima guerra mondiale
non ho chiesto
che sulla mia tomba
fossero recitate
le preghiere ebraiche
anche se le loro cadenze
hanno accompagnato
all'ultimo riposo
tanti dei miei antenati
e anche mio padre
non l'ha chiesto
dice
ma mi sarebbe ancora
più odioso
che qualcuno
potesse vedere
in questo mio sforzo
di sincerità
un rinnegamento
affermo dunque
davanti alla morte
che sono nato ebreo
e che non ho mai pensato
di negarlo
dopodiché precisa
non voglio preghiere
perché anche in questo
non voglio mentire
io non ci credo
e perciò
nemmeno in questo momento
voglio mentire
vorrei che sulla mia pietra tombale
fossero incise
queste semplici parole
di lexit veritatem
ha amato la verità
grazie
grazie a tutti
a domani sera
grazie